Explore the realm between the physical and the virtual.
The offline and the online, creating a cross - world experience.
Hyundai brought the next social media evolution to the renowned...
...Amsterdam motor show, AutoRai 2011.
Not only were hundreds of thousands of visitors met with the finest cars,...
...but Hyundai went the extra mile to spice up the experience even further...
...by offering a new social media adventure.
At the Hyundai stand, visitors were able to include their...
...online friends in their live experiences...
...at the most high profile automotive event of the Netherlands.
By easily connecting a special RFID tag to their Facebook account,...
...Hyundai visitors were able to instantly share their favorite Hyundai cars...
....with their Facebook friends in an exciting and fun way.
Just a quick scan of the special tag...
...on one of the sleek pillars placed next to each Hyundai model,...
...and a "like" post was automatically placed on their Facebook wall.
Using this cutting-edge method,...
...Hyundai achieved some fascinating results.
During the event more than 10,000 likes were posted on Facebook,...
...reaching approximately two million people online...
...and the Dutch division of Hyundai made thousand new friends...
...on its freshly created Facebook page.
We can proudly say that this made Hyundai the most liked brand...
...and Hyundai's Veloster, the most liked car at the Amsterdam AutoRai 2011.